when we first met sal khan 18 months ago
he was working at home in a converted
closet in the heart of silicon valley
the former hedge fund analyst had
recently quit his job to do something
that at the time sounded a bit strange
right now i'm i'm cash flow negative he
gave up a paycheck with a hefty ambition
to help educate the world online a lot
of people thought i was kind of crazy
obviously you know when every waking
hour you have you would sneak into a
room and make math videos and put them
on youtube people kind of question
you know what's up what originally
started as some math tutoring for a
cousin turned into a global phenomenon
the idea didn't seem so crazy anymore
though khan a brilliant mit and harvard
grad with a wife and two children to
support was slowly starting to run out
of a savings
that's when he learned that one comment
from the right man can change everything
an out of the blue endorsement from bill
gates there's a new website that i've
just been using with my kids recently
called khan academy khan just one guy
doing some unbelievable 15-minute
tutorials it was surreal i mean it's one
of those things where you know it's this
person that you grew up knowing kind of
almost a hero most of your life all of
your life soon gates kicked in a million
and a half dollars he also won two
million from google it had a contest to
see who had the best ideas to better the
planet we did now have millions of
dollars to essentially pursue the dream
a dream that's enabled him to post more
than 2300 videos on a host of different
subjects from math to history to
economics it involves an expansion of
the central bank's balance sheet khan
has expanded his approach to create a
software platform for classrooms and
he's working closely with one local
school district why don't you start with
reviewing some of these and getting them
out of the way it was literally it
started with me literally saying look my
cousins have a problem i think i have a
solution for my cousin's problem so i
did it and it required pretty much no
resources a little bit of my time it's
like oh wait my cousins liked it and
other people liked it let's keep going
with his newfound fame and resources
this is the worldwide headquarters of
the khan academy khan has been able to
ditch the bedroom closet for an office
and he now has a small staff to take
things to an even higher level